نسال هذا السؤال وهذا تساؤل يطرحها
العلماء والفلاسفه موانه منذ مئات السنين
نحن لا نستمتع بالحزن في الحياه لكن
لماذا نستمتع بالفن الذي يعبر عن حالات
حزينه سؤال وجيه والله هناك اتجاه
مشاهدينا يقول انه الاستمتاع بالاغاني
والموسيقى الحزينه ربما لانها قادره على
التنفيس عن مشاعرنا السلبيه ذات الدراسه
حديثه اجراها باحثون في جامعه تورينتو
وجدت ان السبب في حب الموسيقى الحزينه قد
يعود لدورها في احساسنا
بالتواصل
باختصار هذا النوع من
المشاركه والانتماء واننا في النهايه لا
نعيش وحدنا احد المشاركين في الدراسه يقول
ان الموسيقى صديق وهمي يخفف من شعورنا
بالعزله يقدم الدعم
والتعاطف بلا مقابل مجانا ما يبي شي في
منه مضبوط
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات